nearly 30 years ago Dinesh D'Souza wrote
a book called a liberal education it
described in lurid detail how on college
campuses the American Left had gone from
championing free speech to stifling it
conservatism under Reagan had become a
potent force a liberating optimistic and
patriotic alternative to the malaise and
pessimism of the 1970s the faculty in
the administration of campuses became
dominated by liberals who were desperate
to turn young minds away from Reaganism
in the America he represented which
these activists maintained let's face it
has inherently racist and sexist because
its founders were privileged white men
conservatives challenging the liberal
orthodoxy on campus were sued maligned
and they were maligned by students and
professors alike they were subject to
disciplinary action and even physically
threatened the ultimate goal was to
bully them into silence of course that
effort failed conservatives probably now
see how naive it was to believe that
this squelching of free speech would end
once they left campus instead the left's
propaganda shaped a new generation of
young adults who then parroted all that
malarkey about the patriarchy and then
they came up with their own new phrases
like microaggressions and safe spaces
and white privilege today left-wing
activists use these terms as bludgeons
to intimidate those who disagree with
them from entering the dialogue at all
so for all their talk of inclusion the
left doesn't invite more voices to enter
the public discussion instead they drive
out any dissenting voice and police the
dogma of their own creation generations
later the chilling effect on free speech
and the workplace in the media and in
society at large is palpable we all feel
it and the situation may be worsening a
brook
institutions survey was released last
fall of college students attitudes
toward free speech on campus was really
depressing the researchers asked do you
agree with shouting down a controversial
speaker who comes to campus 51 percent
of respondents said yes and Democrats
were far more likely than Republicans to
agree with stifling free speech on
campus 62 to 38 percent and by the way
women were more likely than men to
believe that so-called hate speech is
not constitutionally protected the
numbers were 49 to 38 percent and by the
way other data indicate that hostility
to free expression is starting even
earlier than college meaning these kids
are picking it up either at home or in
high school junior high or in both
places
this too is super disheartening it is
critical that all of us regardless of
where we fall on the ideological
spectrum recognize the perilous road
that we're on think about it if 40 to 50
percent of the country feels like their
right to free expression is less worthy
of protection than that of any
garden-variety leftist what does that
leave our First Amendment as a shell of
its former self is the answer there is a
contraction of free speech all around us
and few seem to even notice many of you
have become accustomed to editing
yourselves let's face it expressing
views that just 5 or 10 years ago we're
considered mainstream can now get you
fired it can cause you to lose a
promotion
or you could be branded a hater or yes
you can get boycotted sadly with people
like Christopher Hitchens and Nat
Hentoff gone there are only a handful of
true liberals left on the scene to
defend the vigorous exchange of ideas of
a boycott
job once it is wrong you should we do
this by team it is the modern way of
cutting off free speech and the
goalposts by the way are forever moving
every day more issues are taken off the
table altogether and may no longer be
debated at all so in other words if
you're against affirmative action you're
a racist
and if you wear a make America great
again hat to a gun-control rally and get
beaten up well don't expect a lot of
sympathy from the attendees and if you
praise the military skill of robert e
lee you're liable to be branded a
defender of slavery in the new york
times remember what happened during the
campaign when some left-wing nutcases
and san jose got their hands and a trump
supporter this is the intolerant left in
action whether it's striking voices from
social media or driving certain
viewpoints from the airwaves beating
people up organizing boycotts for
perceived unforgiveable offenses or
preventing speakers from being heard on
a college campus it's all coming from
the same place a desperate desire to
stop debate by branding your opponent
unacceptable and driving him or her from
the public square in just the past week
while I was on my Easter break we saw
more examples of the totalitarian agenda
in action popular black conservatives
diamond and silk noticed that their
Facebook fans weren't receiving
notifications of the new content that
they were posting for months they begged
Facebook for answers well on Thursday
Facebook officially formed them quote
informed them quote the policy team has
come to the conclusion that your content
and your brand has been determined
unsafe to the community well they say
they were never informed about how their
videos our brand were unsafe for their
community or even what the community is
but their fans are still not receiving
notifications and Facebook says there's
no appeal
it feels like we're all again in college
that the speech police demand that you
change your focus change your tone
change the subject or else
then there was conservative writer Kevin
Williamson formerly a nevertrump er at
National Review but he was hired in
March by the Atlantic to great fanfare
well that all changed last Wednesday
when the Soros funded Media Matters dug
up an old podcast where Williams had
described abortion as homicide and he
suggested that it would be should be
treated like any other crime
up to and including hanging that's
pretty rough stuff but so is abortion
the Atlantic editor Jeffrey Goldberg
announced that they were parting ways
with Williamson because quote the
language used in the podcast was callous
and violent this runs contrary to the
Atlantic's tradition of respectful well
reasoned debate and to the values of our
workplace of course millions of
Americans believe that abortion itself
is callous and violent most obviously to
the innocent life it destroys
nevertheless another non liberal voice
was snuffed out at yet another esteemed
publication my friends something
alarming is taking place the free speech
Clause of our Constitution doesn't just
apply to speech that the elites deem
acceptable it exists to support speech
that is by its nature offensive
offensive to people in power offensive
at times to lawmakers offensive to
Facebook and even offensive to the cool
crowd that thinks abortion is just a
sacred right and that Trump himself is a
dangerous dictator we indeed are
reaching a crisis point where cultural
walls are now being erected to
conscripted still free speech in America
but we cannot let this continue at the
end of tonight's show I'm going to be
announcing my response to this
dangerous epidemic and what this show
will do in the coming weeks to expose
the perpetrators their tactics their
major players and their funders their
efforts are Stalinist pure and simple
their objective is a total
transformation of American society not
through rational discourse and open
debate but through personal demonization
and silencing true liberals and
conservatives should defend the freedom
of speech anywhere and everywhere
because the tables can turn very quickly
today its conservatives being targeted
but tomorrow it could be left-of-center
voices as well I say let the debate
continue what the speeches ours don't
seem to appreciate is that there are as
as many or if not more of us than there
are of them and we will never relent and
we will never give in never and that's
the angle